In a few moments,
he will have written the funniest joke
in the world and as a consequence he
will die laughing.
Ah Ha.
I think it's wrong to say either style
of comedy is better.
I find it kind of annoying when people
say British comedy is always smarter,
or whittier.
Have you seen arrested development or 21
jump street or even a spongebob episode?
Be careful,
Patrick.
Being an artist is a heavy
responsibility.
Each work of art is like a child and
must be treated as such.
It was just going to draw a cartoon.
Okay.
Why didn't you say so?
This definitely very smart writing on
both sides of the Atlantic,
but that doesn't answer the question.
What makes them different?
After weeks of research?
My answer is still.
I don't know,
but let's give it a shot.
No one could read it and live.
Oh
No,
no,
I don't.
I didn't change.
I mean the difference,
you know,
if we're talking about the big to
Britain and America,
sorry,
rest of the world.
I think the first step is to take a
British comedy and see how it's American
adaptation changed.
What's the difference between David,
Brent and Michael Scott by season to the
US office begins its movement away from
the UK.
Originally we even see a subtle
cinematic change by brightening the
lights in the office while originally
just a way to differentiate it from the
UK version.
The added brightness seems to serve as a
nice metaphor for the adaptation as a
whole,
but the big differences,
the Americans are more optimistic and
uh,
and last due to the fact that Americans
are told they can become the next
president of United States and
British people to told it won't happen
to you.
And they carry that.
I carry that with them.
There's no doubt that America lightened
up the show.
Michael Scott had his failures,
but there's a hope to it.
In one episode he wasn't invited to
Jim's party,
but shows up anyway,
genuinely hurt and bitter.
Wow.
Who opened the morgue for this thing?
He picks a duet song and no one will
sing it with him.
Reluctantly,
Jim joints in giving Michael a big
cheesy smile and an overall happy ending
to the episode.
But when David Brent performance,
it's still funny,
but at different kinds of funny,
nobody pities him or cheers them on.
They all just watched you.
Been embarrassing.
There's no happy ending and it's not
very hopeful.
Or look at how both characters wrap up
their time on the shelf.
Spoiler alert,
Michael Scott clits to move with his
fiance to call Rato and David Brent begs
for his job back.
I will try twice as hard.
I really,
well I not being complacent and I'll
turn this place around if we just say
that it's not definite now.
And of course this doesn't include the
Christmas special,
which was a lot happier.
Put it this way.
The American coming here like John
Belushi or someone like that is do you
know that scene in a animal house where
the
fellow playing folk music on a guitar
and John Belushi picked up the guitar
and destroys it and the cinema just
smashes it.
And then where goes his eyebrows up a
camera and I want to say,
God,
he's so great with a British comedian
would want to play the focusing.
We want to play the failure.
Get an engine started near the
five by five,
so maybe the difference is the
optimistic American dream versus the
dark British reality.
At least that's what many people think
about it.
Europe is just basically a gene pool of
people whose answers to said,
oh,
don't.
I don't think I can risk their are risk
of America is a gene pool of people say,
well,
that's risky,
but I think that answer is too easy
because you have to ignore the fact that
Americans love the failures like Sean
from Shaun of the dead and plenty of
modern American sitcoms feature losers
who never get their redemption.
Frankly,
I think it's an outdated theory.
The past television era of married with
children and Seinfeld and friends always
featured the classic wise guy who always
had the funny one liner for every moment
to say,
you know how to take the reservation.
You just don't know how to hold it.
I think in the last 10 years,
we're starting to see a self awareness
of this American dream optimism style of
comedy,
and it's always sunny.
There certainly is that feeling of hope
in the characters.
They think they can accomplished
anything,
but they always take it way too far by
becoming violent,
cruel,
and hilariously backstabbing.
It's almost a critique on American
optimism in America.
You're supposed to succeed,
but at what cost?
Completely gone.
We're definitely gonna.
Need a silencer gun?
Find no guns,
no guns up.
Piano wire.
Okay.
Maybe we can use the panel.
Why?
Whatever it is.
Be The guy to pull the trigger on this
thing to mention.
They always fail in face the
consequences and it seems like not one
single thing ever works out for Larry
and curb your enthusiasm.
I need to step out of the car please.
Oh,
come on.
Are you serious?
Did episode of Louie ends with his date
running into a helicopter to escape?
It doesn't get more pathetic than that.
So maybe some American comedy pokes fun
at the hope and lighthearted nature of
past sitcoms,
or maybe American comedy is even
shifting towards that British cynicism
or maybe will always hold that American
optimism in our hearts and even in the
millennial generation where the American
dream seems to do nothing but screw
over.
It'll always be ingrained in our culture
and mindset to shrug it off and keep on
trying.
I'm not gonna take no for an answer
because I just refuse to do that because
I'm a winter and winter is we don't
listen to words like like no or or don't
or stop.
Those words are just not in our
vocabulary.
I know this is a topic a lot of people
get passionate about it,
but I hope the comment section doesn't
get too heated.
At least I don't expect some kind of
Spanish influence.
Nobody expects the Spanish inquisition.
Thanks for watching.
Just a bit of a break for just a little
above that.